got to be the hero of the day he
performed the best of anyone in the
event two wins and a draw
sam
congratulations on your day you must
feel
on cloud nine after yesterday's
disastrous start today you beat fabiano
caruana and then you smash
chakram ahmadirov and this from this
position which i believe you even have a
chestable course on you must be feeling
like this is so and then you draw
nakamura as well kind of a good day at
the office yeah it was nice i mean after
yesterday it was just tough like uh i
had this game with report in round one
where like i'm just slightly better and
uh i make one move and before i hit the
clock like okay this game's over and uh
there's just no ifs ands or butts about
i can resign on the spot and i probably
should have and it's it's sort of hard
to like
lose in one move from like a pleasant
easy advantage like that but i managed
uh and yeah and then wesley played a
great game so it was hard it was a tough
day but uh
one thing i've noticed is i might suffer
a little bit from tilt if i have to play
a couple hours later just right
afterwards but if i have overnight i'm
ready to just come back firing and
that's what i did today
your win against fabi uh was a good one
your thoughts about being able to be the
number two player in the world yeah it
was a pretty normal game for a while i
mean i i think
i wasn't like wildly excited right away
i think i got a very nice position at
some point uh i believe i've just been
better against him like every single
time i've played him with white and i've
drawn every time like he's just a very
good defender so you know getting the
good position was the easy part but
actually putting it away until now had
eluded me uh but so yeah it was it was a
good game uh i was happy with it
you might be mildly happy with that one
but this one with the black pieces the
way you smashed him and i like guys
bring up the board there and talk us
through it because this was really the
pearl of the day from all the games that
we saw and we can pull pull it up on the
screen right there take us to this this
position yes yes and tell us some of the
nuances because the fans want to know so
i had actually just wrote a course on
this for trustable like and one thing i
sort of
uh convinced told myself was once i
published this analysis is that i should
play it occasionally if i play it all
the time then people will just buy my
course and be ready for me but if i
never play it then it will not tax their
preparation time to have to to look into
it so i decided i'm going to play my
chess ball analysis not wildly often but
it will happen so like you know it
should force people to spend some of
their preparation time looking at my
stuff but yeah i had covered this line i
believe that e4 is already a little bit
premature and here
oh sorry look there
just the screen's right there for you
okay yeah so i think e4 is already a
little bit premature uh it's
probably why it's still okay but i
believe that once black can play f5 and
c5
uh the position is a little dangerous
for white if we had this exact same
position with the rook sun e1 and e8
already then i would not be able to play
f5 i'd have to go for knight f6 instead
uh and here i just remember there was a
long time ago or some game that made a
strong impression on it it was like
gurvet shibala i think and it's just
it's a very dangerous position for white
because like if he doesn't get his
knight all sidelined like this if he
takes with the bishop instead on d4 for
example like i was even considering
during the game to go like e5 and say
bishop back to b2 and i think you can
even just chop on f3 and then play e4
and go claim that like this would have
been a bad bishop once you played e4 and
then
just start throwing stuff on the dark
squares and i kind of just think black's
better like it feels very comfortable uh
and then when he played um
yeah and then later on when i played
bishop takes f2 i had to calculate some
lines it took me a second but yeah here
after knight f6 uh knight c3 yeah i mean
i had to calculate there was one detail
that was eluding me otherwise i would
have played this immediately the problem
was after king takes f2 bishop c8 rook
d8 as he played
rook d8 if he hit instead of g4 the move
that was bothering me was queen f3 here
uh because after knight g4 king g1 queen
c5 king h1
let's catch up yeah queen c5 king h1
i couldn't find the win here and i was
calculating this for of course i have a
perpetual if i wanted but i didn't
actually see the win and it's important
that white is exchanged the rooks
because otherwise i would have knight f2
and knight d1 and i was calculating all
the different checks and everything here
and i just couldn't find it but then i
slowed down a little bit and realized
that instead of queen that queen c5 was
a mistake and uh i should instead just
go queen h4 pointing out that the rook
on e1 is now loose and this game is over
and so that might be one side for the
trade yeah once i found that there
wasn't much else to it
nice take us to the line uh i have
something to say about the much else
because in the position when he took on
d8 the queen was hanging at that moment
and you had no interest in taking the
queen and going through that i've
already given a piece so like if i take
on h3 he will take on f8 and take back
on h3 and i suspect that's still very
good for black thanks to the
the pawns but it's certainly in practice
much more unclear and it doesn't take
that much for this to go wrong uh i mean
there i didn't know that maybe queen e3
just works but after rook i calculated
rook takes d and i just believed it one
on the spot because his queen has no
square uh if if queen f3 knight g4 once
i found this queen h4 it's gone if queen
h4 there's knight e4 so
i i believe i'm just taking
stuff back and once i've noticed that
after g4 rook d2 he's completely cooked
there's i think this was a simpler
solution but i suspect bishop which
three would win as well uh in this
position after this he played the move
rook d-1 rook d-1 and here uh the
grandmaster fans sitting over at the
table said just take the bishop on d2
i'm sure that's good enough on b2 and
you said now i'm going to take the pawn
on g4 yeah it's certainly good enough i
don't i think that would definitely work
but this was just more to the point and
yeah i mean at that point i think we're
splitting hairs i understood good
position was dead winning and just
wanted to be as precise as possible i
had plenty of time so it wasn't hard to
spend a little bit to find the best way
proud of a game like this one
yeah i mean it's i don't know it's not
like you it was really weird feeling
when you just sort of crush a really
strong player without
them having a chance or any kind of
resistance uh because they made like one
mistake early on um
uh it's certainly good to to win like
that but i would feel a bit more proud
if yeah i had beaten shock when he was
really on good form and played like a
better game uh
you know it's it's also rapid i mean and
all sorts of mistakes can happen i mean
if you look at the quality of his game
today and then the quality of wesley
playing knight f5 and then me playing a3
with report you'd say who are these
idiots they when why are they being paid
so much money to play like this like but
uh in rapid that can happen and uh
ultimately you know shock showed the
next game he clearly can play some good
chess you're at 50
so not exactly
at the top of the leaderboard but you
must feel decent about your chances
playing great chess today yeah i'm very
happy with how i've played so far i mean
i got i became a very strong classical
player
over some time i was well over 2700 i've
won the us championship but i had just
never really been able to bring rapid up
to the same level as my classical chess
uh and i i've done a lot of work in the
pandemic to try to get better and then
after day one i'm like well
i was just wrong like maybe i still suck
at rapid but today it gives me a bit
more confidence that i played quite a
good day and you know
the other thing about rapid is that
everybody has good days and bad days but
the faster the time control the more
exaggerated your good and bad days will
be so yesterday if it were tournament um
if yesterday was a tremendous loan i
would get last and if today returned
alone i'll get first so that's a pretty
big change uh but yeah who knows maybe
tomorrow will make a boring 50 percent
we hope you play more games like this
congratulations on the day and good luck
tomorrow thanks much congratulations sam
great turnaround well done keep it up